running for president that's why I'm
proud to introduce my running mate today
Infinity Jackson
she has an 80% approval rating and if an
account on Instagram so evidently
there's a videotape with some footage of
you using an offensive Geisler do you
have any idea what I might be referring
to you have any idea what time it is
shut up man I'm not gonna take your
[ __ ] tonight okay what did you say
on the tape
she said buttmunch she called an
obviously gay reporter buttmunch
I want that show see gentlemen I'm gonna
be president at the United States I'm
merely stating a fact I will be
President someday warning you do not
screw with my dream your ambition
frightens me
I want that Chelsea this deserves better
than you do you want to beat them you
need to embrace your inner coldness
unapologetically
got a helping we hit Payton way more
than you do I should kill him yes yes I
do I don't know yet if I'm a good person
you don't have to be a good person as
long as you do good things tell me all
the stuff that would make a difference
to you what do you care about can't
believe it but I'm a stone-cold [ __ ]
with ice water in my veins I want that
Chelsea
this young lady would like to vote she
can't without a student ID otherwise
they bust in a bunch of kids from other
schools to vote illegally
that's insane Astrid is a raging big
that don't understand why calling that
gay man a buttmunch such a scandal
that's what these do lunch butts and
celebrate Halloween I want that Chelsea
we should have him assassinated today I
win at all costs
I have a crime to report did you do it
it's all hard to have to try so hard all
the time you're gonna change the world
how do you know
I want that Chelsea
you